welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor Susan Stokes she is
the John S Satan professor of political
science and director of the Yale program
on democracy professor Stokes research
interests include democratic theory and
how democracy functions in developing
societies with a focus on Latin America
her most recent book is democracy and
the culture of skepticism political
trust in Argentina and Mexico today we
will talk with Professor Stokes about
why leftist parties in Latin American
countries have recently won so much
electoral support welcome professor
Stokes thank you very much you recently
completed a paper on globalization and
the left in Latin America please give us
an overview and tell us some of your
findings well there are two notable
things that have happened recently in
Latin America one is that there's been a
big shift toward what's often called
neoliberalism meaning open markets
relatively open trade with the rest of
the world integration with capital
markets that's sort of on the economic
side and then on the political side
especially very recently there have been
victories by parties of the electoral
left Social Democratic parties sometimes
more left-wing parties and my paper
basically sort of puts those two facts
together it shows that the electoral
success of the Left is largely due or is
it is significantly due to parties at
the right coming to power and opening
trade and decreasing spending and
increasing capital market integration
and those changes tend to help the left
at the ballot box in the next election
okay let's talk a little bit about the
research for the paper I know you you
look at many different countries can you
give us a little overview on the
research that you've done well actually
my interest in a way in some of these
issues goes back to my dissertation
which I did in Peru and long time ago in
the 1980s I was interested in the fact
that uh
left-wing coalition had won elections at
the municipal level in in Lima which was
is a very big important city and so I've
actually been interested in electoral
politics in the left and and ideology
for a long time the current research
project really involved just sort of
keeping keeping tabs on what's been
going on I didn't actually spend you
know enormous amount of time flying
around the region talking to leaders
it's more it's a large statistical cross
national study informed by my own
expertise in Latin America which I've
been studying for ever since I finished
graduate school I was in graduate school
okay so in the countries you've looked
at what is the effect of globalization
and state size on elections in those
latin-american countries well it tends
to help the left in elections especially
when the when rightist parties or
right-leaning parties come into office
and and open up capital markets open up
markets to goods and services and
decrease the size of the state that is
have less government spending that tends
to help the left on average in in the
next election you can see a little bit
of the same pattern may be happening in
the United States in our recent
electoral cycle where a big issue on the
Democratic side was NAFTA and free trade
and and redistributed policies that
tended to concentrate wealth that
probably helped the Democrats and
similar kind of thing is was has been
true in Latin American elections okay so
what is the effect of the left in power
on globalization and on spending well
that's the other side of the story so
part of the story is what happens in
elections when these economic changes
happen and then the second part of the
story is what happens to the economic
changes when the left comes to power and
there the interesting story is that
rather even though the left has
benefited electorally from opening of
trade and and capital markets under
right-wing administrations it doesn't
then once in office
reduce globalization reduce the exposure
of the of the country to international
markets rather it compensates for that
exposure by increasing spending my own
research indicates that the left in
office increases general social spending
and then there are other studies that
suggest that particularly spending on
health and human capital education
increase under the left in in the region
one of the things you touch on in your
paper is an anti biased towards trade
for some of the candidates can you
expound upon that again yeah well that's
the interesting thing they that they are
they've been careful not to promise to
you know cut free-trade agreements or to
increase protectionist tariffs they're
not the candidates in the electoral
campaigns especially the left-leaning
candidates don't go out of their way to
make those kinds of promises but they do
in more couched language suggest that
they'll revise aspects of the Nationals
of the North American Free Trade
Agreement for example and especially in
the Mexican case again very much like
the Obama Clinton debate during the
campaign here it's a matter of sort of
suggesting that globalization is not
entirely good for especially for their
constituents but then once in office I
think there are cross-cutting pressures
that tend to discourage these
left-of-center presidents now from
really closing down on trade it would
hurt some others of their constituents I
think there's a lot of uncertainty about
what the effects of those policies would
be so so instead of doing that they try
to increase spending as a way of sort of
compensating those who are maybe the
losers or who experience more volatility
when when globalization advances in
doing the research was there anything
that particularly surprised you I think
that what surprised me was the degree to
which the Latin American cases were
actually similar to two cases that we
know in the advanced industrial
countries so I went into the project
thinking that believing that
notion that been put out there by other
scholars that there was a dramatic kind
of exceptionalism going on in Latin
America the general finding in the
advanced democracies has been that the
more open a country is to trade on
average the larger the government that
public sector will be and again the the
reason the rationale is that you need a
large public sector to cushion the
effects of globalization it looked for a
long time especially going back to the
1990s as though the Latin American
countries were going in the opposite
direction they were increasing trade and
at the same time cutting very
drastically sometimes cutting that the
the state cutting the public sector the
more I looked into it the more it looked
like it's sort of a story that's not all
that unlike what happened in what
happens in European democracies perhaps
the United States and other advanced
democracies wealthier countries where
the you get an increase in trade that
leads to an increase of social spent of
social spending in general government
spending but only under the conditions
that a left-of-centre or social
democratic kind of government comes to
power but those conditions do tend to
make it more likely that such a
government will come to power so really
the story doesn't look so different from
the one that we're more familiar with in
the advanced democracies the difference
being that the state sector probably
doesn't function as well in Latin
America as an insurance policy against
volatility or as a Redistributor of
resources from the losers from trade to
the wind but from the winners to trade
to the losers I should say ok well
thanks very much for being with us today
and sharing some of your research thank
you very much for more information about
professor Stokes and her research please
visit our website at yale.edu backslash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale